Dance Moms might be on hiatus but dozens
of backstage secrets have yet to be
spilled most of us thought that
competitive dancing couldn't get any
more cutthroat but our opinions changed
once we were introduced to Abby Lee
Miller watch until the end to find out
the real reason why Chloe left the show
in season 4 pyramid the ultimate
confidence crusher Abby Lee Miller has
her own very special way of motivating
her dancers but some might say that her
methods are a little old-fashioned by
now you're probably all aware of Abby's
famous pyramid scheme and how it ranks
her dancers from best to worst if
there's one Dance Moms member who knows
a little thing about coming in last
place it's Chloe Xue cast yet despite
being a super talented dancer Chloe
found herself at the very bottom of the
pyramid week after week which totally
took a toll on her self-esteem but just
when we thought that pyramid day
couldn't get any worse it does and by a
landslide
while the Pearman might have taken about
two minutes of on-air time filming these
sessions usually took about three full
hours Chloe took to YouTube to confess
how humiliating and traumatizing these
sessions used to be funny enough Abby
didn't start using this method until the
reality TV was confirmed so basically
the girls had to sit through three hours
of intense criticism every single week
to spruce up the program's views stand
tall or face the consequences it's no
secret that Abby is a tyrant when it
comes to composure
which is why many of her students felt
uneasy around her while it's only normal
for a dance teacher to want her own
children to have excellent posture while
on stage Abby never let the girls let
their guards down especially not during
pyramid a little known fact is that Abby
bullied her students into standing tall
when they were into her presence Chloe
went in depth about how Abby used to
yell at them for standing with their
hands in front of their bodies in fact
she was only happy when their backs were
straight and their hands were neatly
placed behind them this was especially
obvious during pyramid scenes and since
it was revealed that it took extremely
long to film those scenes the girls got
incredibly restless Abby's not one to
use censored language which is why she
tell her students that they looked like
they'd wet themselves every time their
feet weren't facing the right angles and
their hands were fixed in front of their
midriff knowing this it makes sense that
the girls felt extremely stressed out
whenever their dancing teacher opened
her mouth
often exists being a Dance Moms member
might seem like a fun experience from
the sidelines but many of the dancers
confirmed that they had very little time
to be children most of the girls were
young kids when they joined Abby's
dancing team and their weekly schedules
allowed little downtime according to
Chloe days off basically didn't exist
which was an ideal for the shaping of a
young mind in fact some people might say
that their schedules were borderline
illegal missing rehearsals wasn't an
option and neither was cutting school so
many of the girls struggled to juggle
jam-packed schedules that could burn out
the average adult so while a typical
Dance Moms episode seemed to follow the
girls from rehearsal to competition
their weekly routines were a lot more
strenuous than we were led to believe
according to Chloe just thinking about
her old schedule causes her to clam up
with stress he still has hopes that
Corinne will replace Maddie when Maddie
was on the white van syndrome when you
see a big white van approaching you the
first thing you think about is stranger
danger right well when the girls on
Dance Moms see one their mind
automatically jumps to their go-to
transportation vehicle although a 15
passenger van is never showcased on the
show the girls were made to drive from
competition to competition in this getup
you would think that the girls would
have a more luxurious ride but the
series chose to leave this rundown van
out of the show to maintain appearances
instead of tapping into their budget and
getting the stars as suitable ride they
were made to drive around Los Angeles in
what looked like a kidnapping mobile
although it's been over a year since the
girls were made to drive around in one
of these vans though he says that seeing
one of these is enough to put her in an
anxiety driven state their weight was
monitored finding out that the girls
were made to sign a contract upon
agreeing to star on Dance Moms
isn't exactly life changing however what
the contract highlighted is there are
many reasons why Chloe chose to leave
the show at the end of season 4 but most
of her issues with Abby started when she
and her mother refused to sign the
contract since Chloe was a beloved
member of the group kicking her out of
the show was not an option but that
never stopped Abby from kicking Chloe
out of her studio the dancer was only 12
years old at the time but she knew that
signing a contract that forced her to
monitor her weight was super unhealthy
while being forbidden to change her hair
or get facial piercings wasn't that much
to ask for not gaining weight
according to the dance mom start the
contract forbade any of the girls from
gaining over five pounds so instead of
signing her way into an eating disorder
Chloe chose to stick to her morals they
had no time to practice the reality TV
shows immediate success cause the girls
scheduled to take a huge hit
Thursday's were reserved for learning
their solos and practicing for upcoming
shows but things didn't always go
according to plan
while most dancers take up to six months
to perfect their solos in time for
competitions the girls are made to
master their performances in one single
day in fact sometimes they only had
about half an hour to learn their
routine before hitting the road knowing
this just confirms what we already knew
these girls are super talented and if
having one single day wasn't bad enough
there were times when the dancers had to
learn their routines while on their way
to competitions but in order to make
their solos look flawless they were made
to film their performances twice once
for the judges and once more for cameras
we can't even begin to imagine how
stressful that must be for them but
suddenly their hissy fits and tears make
perfect sense
sticks and stones we're so used to
hearing bad things about Abby that many
of us believe her to be the devil
reincarnated however according to Chloe
Kalani and Kendall
Abby actually helped them become the
people they are today you would never
expect these words to come out of their
mouths but hey they said it not us
during an interview with studio 10 the
girls came clean about how Abby's tough
love and criticism helped them become
better dancers in the long run sure her
methods might have been crude so much so
that the girls mothers threatened to
pull their daughters out of the show on
more than one occasion but despite all
the tears and anxiety Abby flung their
way her students love and appreciate
everything she's done for them now
that's pretty shocking right especially
since many of her students have cut all
contact with their old dance teacher
sticky funds were more than a little low
you would think that every single Dance
Moms member made a boatload of cash from
the get-go but this would be false
according to Christi the first few
seasons were all about the girls and
seldom about money
in fact the show's budget was so low
that the moms barely made 600 dollars
throughout the first season and worst of
all the children didn't even make a
penny
while this might have changed once fun
started rolling in paychecks were split
between cast members for the first few
seasons for this reason both moms and
daughters were made to design and create
their costumes for the majority of the
series so basically those who weren't
nimble with a needle and thread plunged
into the craft overnight more than that
the girls were also responsible for
doing their own makeup while there were
times when their hair and makeup were
done professionally
this was rare so before long the Dance
Moms crew became Naturals at doing it
yourself from documentary to reality TV
show it's all news that the dancing
industry is extremely competitive and
merciless knowing this lifetime chose to
direct their energy to the industry
choosing to film a six-week documentary
that would follow Abby and her dancers
Nia practically begged her parents to
join the production but they refused to
let her audition but before long the
dancers persistent nature prevailed and
she went in for an interview
despite being convinced that they were
too boring to make the cut folly soon
found out that she and her daughter were
chosen for the special but once the
cameras came in and started capturing
livid fights between the dancers parents
lifetime saw Abby's studio as a golden
opportunity and sooner than later the
documentary was scrapped and producers
opted for a reality TV series the fights
weren't scripted it goes without saying
that many reality TV shows are scripted
and although Dance Moms isn't completely
innocent of this most of the show's
drama was 100% real this is especially
true when a concerning Abby and her
students mothers since Abby is a
wild-card who won't hesitate to insult
her dancers it's only normal that the
girls mothers jump in to defend their
daughters
according to Nia the network would never
have picked up the show if it weren't
for the intense drama that went down in
every single episode so while some
scenes might have been scripted the
fights were completely authentic
one tutor to rule them all being a
full-time dancer in a part-time teenager
is no cup of tea which is why most of
the girls had to resort to being
homeschooled
Nia revealed that to get their grades
where they needed to be the crew had to
rent a doctor's office across the street
where the girls could receive their
lessons since the girls education wasn't
interesting enough to make the
director's cut it a hire a tutor to
teach them what they needed to know
whenever they had time
so for about
seven years the little dancers shared a
teacher who taught them various subjects
funny enough many of the girls weren't
in the same grade which made their
educational needs different the
green-eyed Abbe
Abby's personal success took off long
before Dance Moms was ever on the map
which is why we didn't expect her to be
greedy when it came to money after all
all her students parents paid a handsome
amount of cash for their daughters to be
taught by her so imagine everyone's big
surprise when Abby wanted her students
to pay her 10% of their Dance Moms
revenue this infuriated many of the
mothers especially since they were
hardly making any money at the beginning
of the show despite thinking more than
everyone else Abby wanted a cut of
everyone's profits and she was
determined to make them sign 10% of
their earnings away but when it came to
Chloe and Christi they refused to give
in to her demands has anyone seen Abby
Abby might be the star of the show but
she sure didn't put in as much effort
into the program as we were led to
believe well every episode of Dance Moms
showcase Abby through and through the
truth of the matter is that Abby was
hardly ever in the studio well we're
sure that she had her reasons the dance
teacher wasn't exactly easy to get ahold
of Jill Kira and Christi made it clear
that Abby was basically a ghost when it
came to filming the show however the
show's editors found clever ways to make
it look like she spent days in the
studio without ever leaving this is news
for many of us especially since Abby is
the show's pride and joy according to
Jill the crew sometimes had to wait
hours for Abby to make an appearance
but hey Abby's a busy lady Chloe's
condition although many dancers are
forced to face heavy criticism it's safe
to say that their appearance should be
left out of the equation but when it
comes to Abby's teaching methods we all
know that she likes to take things to a
whole new level
Chloe was never Abby's favorite student
but that doesn't mean that she deserves
to be made fun of for something she
can't control as many of you know Khloe
has silent sinus syndrome which causes
one of her eyes to be smaller than the
other
Chloe received a lot of heat on the
internet and had to cope with people
telling her that she had a lazy eye and
that she was ugly but she didn't let it
get to her head however when Abby made
fun of her eyes during a temper tantrum
her self-esteem took a major
so the real reason behind Chloe leaving
Dance Moms is that Abby made fun of her
appearance making her feel like no
twelve-year-old should ever so there you
have it guys the biggest Dance Moms
secrets brought to you by the cast
itself before you go make sure to let us
know who your favorite Dance Moms member
is and that's a wrap make sure to hit
that subscribe button to be the first in
line to watch all of our newest videos
thanks for watching and see you next
time on the things
[Music]